hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch the honest trailers for
truth damn I'm excited to check this out
man I really did love this movie honest
trailers gonna do a good job listen
you're gonna hear me mention this all
the way leading up to the actual day I
am doing this I am hosting a panel at
comic-con at the hoarding Grand Theatre
I was looking actually looking at the
Horde and Grand Theatre if there's so
many big panels that actually go on it
over 200 people are already reserved who
attend the panel that I'm at it's for
the new TV series dark web it's an
Amazon exclusive series 8 episodes I
actually saw the first two last night
it's really good I was a little planning
on watching one but then because of how
good it was it was like watch the second
one I highly recommend if you guys are
at Comic Con to please stop by attend
the panel it's Friday July 19th at 1:30
p.m. that's also the same day the series
premieres on Amazon there's a lot of
really cool actors in the series people
like Shpongle a Melampo from lost in
space Lana McKissack there's been
Transformers Michael nardelie I've been
seeing her name wrong no Emmy Gonzalez I
think that's how you say it also Gabriel
Lunas in this series and planning on
watching the rest before we head over to
Comic Con it's really good and I'm not
bullshitting you at all please go check
it out I'm probably gonna stop by and
say hi to the stranger Peace Corps at
Comic Con as well
let's watch this Shazam trailer
presented by the boys taking the fight
of superheroes on have a son prime video
on July 26 roughly sprouts and toddlers
keep a lookout for our boys reaction
right for the kid inside everyone just
let you know actual kids she's there
meet Billy Batson he's got the street
smarts aboard citizen and the street
Tyrone Biggums haha Billy explored into
a cave by an old man who claims to be a
wizard which to be clear kids is never a
good idea
Maness he'll become one of DC's classic
characters captain part all know he used
to be Captain Marvel the DC changed it
to Shazam that's Kazaam
I need the got obsessed with being
worthy and lightning know the street
brand gets wish fulfillment powers three
wishes to be exact okay it's the one
where Chuck forces gather round for a
heartwarming tale that out families fast
to the Furious that's pushing away his
family Marvel has bad dads yes ass Billy
learns that family isn't about him
abandoned you at a carnival one of them
it's about the people you're forced to
live with who love you because you're
constantly singing their ass
thank you
but Shazam we'll have to fight more than
just the overburden foster care system
he's up against dr. sivana
a veteran character actor out for
revenge on DC for casting him S&S Green
Lantern
watch you know one thing yeah it's a
representation of a different human
failing with unique powers that actually
you know never mind they're on this kind
of brain block sample the rock cannot
get here fast enough does the next one
really have to be about the very angry
caterpillar they're phantoms follow-up
question what so cheer along as DC
finally cracks the code on making a
heartwarming fun inspiring movie about
an invincible strong man a super man if
you win that gives kids everything they
dream of no not turning into a 38 year
old and a styrofoam muscle sue no not
terrorizing the boys who make your life
a living hell I'm talking about a kid's
ultimate power fantasy developing a
moderate YouTube hallway story you're a
wizard Billy the movie trying to write
the starring section Boris not so easy
is a kid chief of staff see villain
he came here just for me wizard Burt
Ward of the stage
greeting Titans go an amount of r.kelly
references believe
make a live-action gargoyles movie
covers with washing now please yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's okay this is the second DC film
with an Annabelle cameo so the country
to never see there's already matters
going
this episode was brought to you by the
hands a new series on Emma's oh I did
not know Annabelle was in that store no
more mr. nice guy the week is long the
silver cat feeds when blue meets yellow
in the West Wow have I was there yeah I
had no idea yeah they're connected when
I saw Aquaman the second time people
told me where to look good and finer
them that's why you got to buy that
blu-ray going through and scour every
scene well that animal ones a lot easier
spot yeah it makes a whole lot more
sense
I just remembered Zachary Levi I was
watching a GTV there was like a five
minute video about Zachary Levi he was
actually the top contender for guardians
of the galaxy it was down to him and
Chris Pratt what ended up happening was
you know Chris Pratt got the role and he
fell into this strong state of
depression I never thought about because
he was saying that he was suddenly seen
the role that he believed he was gonna
get he was seen Chris Pratt everywhere
you know like the promos for everything
Chris Pratt here on TV the internet
posters it was hard to avoid so he
thought is an insanely hard depression
[ __ ] this is really actually moving
inspiring video where star to get mental
health treatment he got completely clean
he didn't even think he had a shot at
Shazam it was it was a self tape
audition than he did for it and then he
ended up booking Shazam I was like a
dream come true so he's become this like
major advocate for mental health so
who's actually like super inspiring to
see all this so he got this role at the
right time and I think this role fits
him so perfectly based off what I was at
least seeing in this video yeah of a
person with a sort of boyish wonder
naturally but with a really kind heart
as well and I've watched that last
week so watching this now I even have
this like extra appreciation for Shazam
well yeah and I have that experience and
to get cast in a movie that is a bit
more heartwarming and has a bit more of
a warmth to it generally I think
actually is kind of one of those maybe
an example I don't know how he feels
about her if he wishes he did guardians
over this but it seems like a good
example of hold tight because maybe
something better will come along or
something more suited to you will come
along and he's so terrific and Shazam
and the funny thing is like he's also in
like a bunch of Thor movies and yeah
ever no yeah fun thing they pointed out
it I mean kudos to every one of the
writers working this honest trailer as
well as John Bailey for doing the voice
over here but they put it out about the
moms in the DC Universe the sad moms
because I remember watch they're there
Marvel Cinematic Universe on this
trailer and they pointed out all the
things about dads like oh yeah those
little thing about dads and then I
didn't even put together the correlation
between the moms that are in the DC I
remem that's an intentional studio thing
like there already got the best let's do
the moms but it is a funny little
connection to make know each comic book
label has a different member of the
family be their problem you know yeah
like Dark Horse Comics it's always
brothers in comics it's always sisters
and so on one thousand a hundred million
percent right here I like what they said
about the seven deadly sins because that
is one of my major complaints with the
movie as much as I love Shazam if I
thought it was a really really great
film those seven deadly sins are not
distinct they're really not yeah pretty
much the same thing oh they're creepy
but they could have each had a power
tailored to their specific look and they
were I'm like oh that's clearly who that
is
yeah I'm like in that final moment with
I forget what's in it was the final one
Matt I think it was envy he was able to
identify envy just through a process of
elimination and after being able to tell
what makes his personality and look
distinct here they're all different but
they're not all distinctly different
definitely not what did happen which is
am to youtube channel that's a great
what happened what's his answer
they went viral they had to have been
making money they must have I mean like
if their videos montage do they hit
minerals do they have it longer than 10
minutes you would think they all fly
with yellow dollar people science for
illegal violent crimes
and some of them Atlanta legal claims
yeah you know something's gotta be
monetizable on that channel yeah man you
know there's more realistic than
wreck-it Ralph see YouTube channels so
you got to give them credit for that
when I watch a superhero film or a
Disney animated movie I look for realism
mm-hmm when they're developing YouTube
channel yes exactly
oh by the way we have a boy's reaction
coming out this week so keep a lookout
for that on another amazon amazon
exclusive series yeah kind of like dark
web
yeah let's go bright a full-circle hole
I guess so many things planned at
comic-con I fortunately had to reject
the offer to be part of the movie fights
panel at Comic Con for screen junkies if
I have time I'm planning on at least
like running on by to be in the audience
to show some support either way I think
that if you guys are at comic-con course
go check out you know my panel for a
dark web at the Horten grand theater but
also make sure to go check out screen
junkies is Comic Con panel because it's
gonna be great and I was fortunate after
participant there WonderCon one I'm sad
I won't be able to make I just can't
commit to it if I'm there I'll say how
do you either way go to their Comic Con
panel it should be Friday night thank
you guys for watching what was your
favorite moment in Shazam leave a
comment below you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell hit the like button and we'll catch
you guys soon